and one has to stay in I was about 11 or
12 years old
several people held me down then they
cut me they laid me on the table I can
still picture it I had such horrific
pain then they sewed me together they
tied my legs together for a month so
that the wound would heal types of
female genital mutilation vary anywhere
from damaging the clitoris to sewing up
the vaginal opening in some countries
the brutal practice is considered a rite
of passage or prerequisite for marriage
in Somalia the procedure is done by your
so called cutter they have no idea what
they're doing they just have a knife and
a razor and they cut after two and a
half years in Germany 36 year-old e4a
seeking advice at berlin's doesn't
flower center which offers
reconstructive surgery and consultation
for women affected by FGM dr. Cornelius
Trent's advises those effects end but
Germany services and expertise in FGM
are still limited when I studied
medicine FGM wasn't covered in the
subject but I know this is changing and
I hope that trend continues but I still
meet colleagues who either know very
little or absolutely nothing about FGM
according to Ted a firm some 65,000
women affected by FGM a living in
Germany an increase of 12% on last year
the sleek for Alameda on this is due to
the increase in migration from countries
where female genital mutilation is
particularly prevalent for Germany this
means countries like Somalia Eritrea in
Iraq Somalia Eritrea and Iraq in a
statement to Deutsche Welle Germany's
family and women's ministry described
female genital mutilation as a human
rights violation during this legislative
period the ministry also plans on
working more closely with Germany's
youth welfare offices but when it comes
to some parents taking their young
daughters back to their home country for
a so-called vacay
circumcision there's very little that
authorities or the German government can
do volunteers and teachers therefore
play a huge role the Antigua nuclei
only way to really gauge what's going on
is to have a vigilant society that
particularly means people who work in
close contact with families who might
potentially subject their daughter to
FGM these people should be particularly
attentive these artists lenders I'll
make some sign tariffs AM estimates that
fifteen and a half thousand girls living
in Germany are in danger of FGM efj
reveals her three-year-old is among them
my three-year-old daughter hasn't been
circumcised yet but if we sent back to
Somalia I'm 100% sure that her
grandparents will make her undergo the
procedure but for EFA's eldest three
daughters it's already too late that was
our fate those of us who had to
experience that but I'm a fighter I hope
that these women are healthy and I hope
that at some point this ritual will stop